[Musique]
un vrai show moteur me cesaris je sais
pas ce que je deviendrais s'en fout mais
si ça arrive c'est la discrétion
incarner j'oublierai son existence si
elles n'estimaient pas si pire du
poignet voilà ce qu'on est violette les
femmes invisibles
ministère souligne pour une toilette de
la porte rien n'a d'importance m'ont
aidé adorerais me voir dans une robe
dior ça fait bien longtemps que la
guerre est terminée ton et 10 reviendra
plus jamais
de mal à rêver atteint vous êtes une
rêveuse je ne vois bien
vous auriez dû percevoir une pension de
veuve de guerre vous allez toucher une
sacrée somme qu'est ce que tu vas faire
je vais me payer une robe christian diot
je vais à paris
[Musique]
excusez mon ma jolie je viens pour
m'acheter une robe une des robes à 500
livres pour nous tromper l'adresse
madame c'est moi vous espoir que
maintenant quand en dix minutes j'ai
économisé le moindre penny gagner à
récurer les temps pour me faire une en
mai hommage ce serait pour moi un
honneur de vous inviter à découvrir la
collection à mes côtés
[Musique]
ça c'est très joli
une robe dior est conçu pour éblouir
comment vous y prendrez vous mes
services pour n'être personne vous est
invisible
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui m'a pris de venir ici je
ne suis qu'une femme de ménage de
londres et non vous êtes une femme de
ménage qui reste de la plus belle robe
du monde il ne coûtait vous fabriquez
des pluies des toiles il avait le
courage de croire en vos rêves mystery
jets étaient sol bien trop longtemps à
rêver ma vie au lieu de la ville alors
surtout ne faites pas ça
je n'avais jamais rencontré quelqu'un
comme vous
ordu la femme a changé c'est une femme
moderne je croyais qu'il était trop tard
maintenant je ne sais plus
[Musique]
c'est chris mullin et bien c'est le
maître en personne monsieur dior ou dix
villes typiques et librement l'est